[Music]
foreign
what's going on chat I see you guys in
there
up to no good don't think I don't see
that
already 20 people in this chat just to
see me Phil you know why you guys are
here don't act like you don't act dumb
I'm not playing by the way it's just
going on over and over again
ugh
so
uh once King finishes his game of uh
Fortnight then we'll get going we'll get
started guys
do you want me on YouTube
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
burrito
[Music]
burritos burrito
[Music]
burritos
burritos
burritos
burritos
burrito
burrito
here ridiculous
you're ridiculous
you're ridiculous
how big do you guys want this camera to
be
foreign
[Music]
all right so
so what what
some of these characters man I I don't
know these characters names like that
um put in the chat what characters you
think's gonna gonna end me
King says King and hippo
I don't even know
is King Hippo like the last boss or
something
someone said glass Joe
if I can't beat someone called class Joe
it's an issue all that Mario is the
referee
the start button
we're about to start guys we're about to
start let him finish last
boss one hit knockout I I I mean
most likely won't get to the won't beat
the game or anything like that
starring little man
appreciate you calling uh you coming
into the realm Caitlin Brown
Catalan Brown
welcome to the bronze man put put some
logos in the chat for him man put some
logos in the chat put some shields in
that chat welcome welcome the new member
to the to the round man welcome back
mm-hmm
we've got to
I don't know what we're about to see oh
God solving here with the 20 super check
[Music]
uh you guys are ridiculous let me share
this out on Twitter by the way since
we're waiting for King
people people be there the moment they
think you're gonna struggle they want to
see it
appreciate it hustle you made it easier
to find the link to the
all right
[Music]
playing
punch
out for
the first time
sure to pull up and see
okay now let's
put that in there let's get that out
there
we about to start guys we about to start
um Paris Lockhart in here man people
really want to want to see this
can you guys hear the
[Music]
thank you
uh you'll be able to hear the audio
Paris uh once I actually start it's just
there's no audio at the beginning
apparently
like once I start the actual thing I
think you should be able to hear just
fine
shout out to the 32 people showing up
here to see me lose
now we know why they're here you know
what's going on
we're about to see we're about to see
I hear the audio but not twice yeah I
fixed it I had it playing in the
background
might see her age quote today you might
it takes a lot to rage quit me though
like to me
to me to like
leave violently
all right King I'm giving you like two
more minutes on the starter
he's on his knees Behind The Rock
[Music]
[Music]
how well can you guys here came you hear
him pretty good
Colossus
[Music]
you guys should be able to hear King
I'm right here guys
I'm coming
yeah he's talking you got do you guys
hear him okay I hear you how well does
he sound
I actually sound divine okay we're not
going that far how well does King sound
does he sound fine incredible baby
okay all right I played Sports and here
I go
all right well I'm starting the first
part
yeah baby
oh Punch Out live here we go
look cool
[Music]
shaved up ready to fight and actually
you're cold I don't know why it looks
like I ate mustard
yeah you do look pretty crazy
yo look how he'd be looking man
[Music]
I don't want to get it
[Music]
all right put the betting lines up
anybody who got uh
[Music]
it's supposed to hurt yeah
[Music]
oh God
[Music]
are you tired bro
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's my guy
[Applause]
skilled got skills
oh what is this
[Music]
oh here we go
oh no
[Music]
oh no
spintex
[Music]
oh
my man
[Music]
that's right second round TKO
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I wonder what those stars do
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
baby I told you my money
bro
look at his eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was using my analog stick so now
oh yeah digital baby
[Music]
[Applause]
on his back like that oh what's with the
Stars that people talking about you got
Stars man
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
I don't know how to bring the manual up
it's awesome I have no clue how to bring
the manual up
[Music]
it used to be the star button do you oh
are you in the title pal
look how small I look this is so unfair
we fighting grown man
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know how to dog that that
comical stuff
[Music]
around here
[Music]
baby
[Music]
baby
get up baby
[Music]
what's this dude's name
[Music]
all right
get up
[Music]
I thought I could like knock him out
[Music]
it ain't that way though
mag
how many rounds is there
[Music]
I feel like I'm getting stomped right
now
y'all do what you gotta do man your face
looking it up come on
your eyes
stop it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and then fake it from there
[Music]
thank you
oh my God after you hit him try a super
fun
[Applause]
yo that's how you do it at it
[Music]
when you start them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
what's going on chat what's going on hit
that like button man hit that like
button
float like a butterfly sting like with
Steve a mosquito shut up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shut up
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
I'm done
then
we go so addict as that preparation for
our next fight they get stun them and
you have a star please hit it with a
super punch
so what what what is the indication that
he has a stone when it pops up over his
head that you gotta stop when he's
stunned like when he's just sitting
there oh you punch him in the face for
the first time he's stunned
oh I'm fighting them already
that's right are you ready for this
you ready yeah
[Music]
it's a jail
oh there you go
there we go
[Music]
oh no
in my experience when people rush in
that's coming
you can hit the body
again
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
you know test your skills
[Applause]
there we go you hit him now you can't
wear the super punch that's a
combination
ding ding
gotta shoot all super trap for color
brown attic Block Please I have no clue
how to block and two dollar secrets from
Malcolm W I appreciate the super chats
guys oh my God he got my guy with the
one-eyed Bandit
[Music]
I don't know what the button
configuration is
[Music]
thank you
my combo oh okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go come on man let's go at it come
on one more time baby it's very early
[Music]
dude
[Music]
[Applause]
man that is that don't even make sense
oh
[Music]
man
hey I don't even understand that
[Music]
someone will come in there with the
exact amount of stand where they walked
in that [ __ ] stop the King stop it
and sometimes in Boston when the head
doesn't work the bodies the answer
don't be afraid to stare that bull down
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I always have a hard time dodging this
big move
[Music]
uh Conor McGregor is a slick one he gets
to get memorized by the mustache you see
it is
oh
you should work on the body here
[Applause]
I know I don't want two punches good man
gotta figure out how to get some body
shots
[Music]
no punch into the space
[Music]
just there you see that's the body
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how about let's go next round Donald
McGregor's on to the next round kind of
move like a face looks like a total race
but The champ is good
got two losses he wins two losses come
on man come on
[Music]
uh can't have Conor McGregor doing this
to you man dropping you in this manner
the champion you see
oh man oh come on
come on
[Music]
oh what the hell is happening
time
yo let's go okay come on
you should get up about four yeah
[Applause]
here we go
try to beat the buttons while he's down
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go Conor McGregor has been
defeated for the third time
he started this harder and harder now
let's go to addicts babadook piston
Honda
[Music]
don't say nothing
[Music]
uh-huh oh
[Music]
um
[Applause]
hey you ever tried to like weave one of
those shots that he throw and punch him
in between it
[Music]
catch
[Music]
that total faith in here
oh look at that weed he looked at the
porch as it slid past his face
[Music]
all right
[Music]
goes Daddy
[Music]
attic happened to To Be A Champion
charity put it together
[Music]
[Applause]
attic
beat the button get your health back
come on buddy
[Music]
no actually I'm not
remember I just made it to Mike Tyson
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
round up
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
you've come up here give his best
against Twisted Honda
[Music]
uh I wish you could call a friend and
pass the controls
[Music]
but we'll go back down to Canada and we
will hone our crap
[Music]
oh man
Noob
it's glass yo hey yo what do you know
bro
[Music]
there's me attic from the IOP
[Music]
so when I'm not diving in sewers I'm a
referee
[Music]
boom
[Music]
stop running man hit you like that
[Applause]
Boogie Bear Boogie Boogie all down
there
we go
see
[Music]
oh
oh really much
[Music]
thumbs up
[Music]
all right sweet champ listen guys tomato
can he's washed up at it come on give it
all you got
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go yeah
[Music]
[Music]
glass still looking like a Defender
[Music]
you saw how you went down
[Music]
yeah you gotta watch these things you be
very observing watch all around you all
right now we got Conor McGregor coming
up and we know how Conor McGregor does
he gave me by his mustache
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah can we get a Flawless round
[Music]
you don't care about what you're talking
about
[Music]
[Applause]
it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I try to catch a baby just knock him lay
me like I feel like my character ain't
faster
okay I mean hey
[Music]
I think timing is the key in this game
not necessarily how big you are how
strong y'all really has everything to do
with time
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
cool cool
[Music]
jazz
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go come on got enough time in
this round to put this bomb away send
this tomato can back out of here
[Music]
oh no
oh
[Music]
next round
got your eye looking sleepy again that's
nothing that's weird
all right let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go at it come on 40 seconds
into round number two you dropped
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one minute 19 seconds you dropped the
second time
at the first sign of danger is
anything's going all the way up
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
let's go I don't care so what he had to
restart the game
baby
[Music]
New York City
[Music]
taking all these bumps series today
don't get used to hand it uh it's
knocked down again oh hey Google
hey Forte yo I'm gonna take you I'm
gonna take you over to this where this
area is at in New York you're gonna see
this exam exact thing
oh that's my dude
okay
[Music]
it's a special dude
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh they're different over here Paul
[Music]
okay wow
[Music]
[Music]
round one
don't forget
to talk about being here to watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go that's my guy
very easy
[Music]
attic dropped and attic that's the
formula it's over for you Johnny baby
send it down out of here you know it's
Xbox do not like God
[Music]
oh no
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right all right let's go next next
one
next round is coming he knows what to do
[Music]
well you got the lean back out
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
there we go at it
good job
[Music]
man it's like how do I run out of energy
no no no no
[Music]
[Applause]
one more drop
but you ain't getting no stars just need
one more drop
you can't get scars on this dude
[Music]
[Music]
about it
we got a couple of seconds left
[Music]
nope
yeah yeah
let's go let's go at it let's go
let's go
and here's where the game's over
foreign
fun guys
[Music]
because
[Music]
info
[Music]
that round one was great
all right don't worry about your eye
leaning a little bit
it's high it is all right man it may be
good your man over there got that crowd
gotta knock that cool stuff oh God
[Music]
[Music]
oh you better
oh
it's calling King for nothing awesome
[Music]
good job beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
because I don't know how to hit him
you ever tried blocking
magnets
my boy face look like hamburger
but we gonna try something different
[Applause]
[Music]
here we go George Foreman
I saw your forming Grill oh wait
[Music]
get up you stupid dude
[Music]
[Music]
have them
[Applause]
oh they're gonna do a rematch immediate
oh snap
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
okay I already found out the secret
[Music]
[Applause]
it may be a wrap the king if more people
addict that's got the formula
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]
and there goes my money that I would
have lost
oh yes the Great Tiger
[Applause]
[Music]
yes sir
[Music]
sometimes they give you a little visual
cues
[Music]
[Music]
on down
[Music]
you got that two step one
[Music]
just Instant Transmission stuff on me
[Music]
you nasty son do you have to get Stars a
certain way yep
foreign
ER has a different way for you to
produce Stars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hahaha
addict about his secret
[Music]
in between rounds pushing buttons like
nothing's working
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but you did get a cold
[ __ ] that code
[Music]
better use the code
uh
[Music]
let me reset someone get that code for
me
because I I understand people ain't
gonna want to see me play the first the
same people over and over again someone
get that code from you go back in the
chat get that code for me
[Music]
I'm gonna beat this Egyptian looking
bastard someone get that code for me
[Music]
don't they they should have the menu so
you can see what the buttons are for you
[Music]
I don't know
Maybe
there's a check for codes
[Applause]
[Music]
when you press continue that's when you
put the code in
yeah I got to get the code real quick
so you said it was when
King
oh okay shout out the hustle shout out
to hustle he went and got me the code
also was that guy yeah zero
zero five
man
[Music]
seven
[Music]
five four how do I go back I can't can I
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
man
could you imagine when you was a kid
I'm actually enjoying this so much I
don't understand why they don't make it
[Music]
the formula will be hold up right now I
think it'd still be a fun game well you
might not sell millions but it would be
a fun game
well that's why they have the store for
you to go play you know punt down a
super punch up
I'm gonna tell you that super punch out
if you think it's a fun Super Punch Out
takes it up a notch
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
someone in the chat told me how to get
stars for this dude I can beat him I
just want to be the best
I know what do you know maybe it might
be to the body
the body might be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stones
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you haven't received that one star yeah
it's two times
[Music]
ah
oh no
oh Adam you had him this round
I I know I'm trying too hard to find out
how to do stars off I apologize
[Music]
no one asked for your opinion
I am if you're a trainer
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hit me straight off the bed and he's
like you're going way over there we
ain't even doing it
oh my god get up
[Music]
[Music]
I'm done oh no
[Music]
I can't hit him in the gut it wasn't
working can you lying to me I'm not
lying to you man I'm telling you certain
things
it's all about time
take that flower shove it up
you know what that's how basically
that's what happens
[Applause]
[Music]
everything is off of a stun
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
weed first we punch we punch
I think it's Blitz he wouldn't stop
go go go
oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
book maybe that knocked down the way you
did it is the way to go I wanna know how
to get a start don't make me Google this
okay
Google we didn't have Google back then
what we do now it's the 21st century
huh
I see you playing back in time right now
you got a call you gotta um
go up to game packs
[Music]
wait till you open his big mouth addict
[Music]
[Music]
do this to you
[Music]
a little bit too slow buddy
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
King Hippo
around what was the dozie foreign
[Music]
hit man don't give up Little Mac did oh
my God
[Music]
oh okay here we go
I'm trying to
Oh What A Drop
[Music]
trying to learn how to like train my
mind
[Applause]
also it's an automatic
sure
[Music]
all right here we go you Egyptian master
[Music]
that's racist on a whole nother level
oh man
[Music]
there we go come on attic
I got one more before I have to shoot
all over
laughs
[Music]
thank you
there we go They're gonna stop
where that star came from his gut drop
oh yeah come on
you don't let him beat you don't let
that diamond Dazzle you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
dinner
[Music]
that'd be crazy could you imagine if you
had a star in portal with that I don't
think he'll get up
[Music]
sleepy time bedtime
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
maker
[Music]
hey he got posted in the nose
attic is looking like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
disappear on me
[Music]
I think I got him I think I got him you
got them man you can feel it you feel
that adrenaline pumping in your heart
little MacBook
[Music]
there you go addict there you go thank
you
[Music]
so we've got fun setup
[Applause]
oh no
[Applause]
we don't drop
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
here we go come on good block good point
[Music]
accidentally pressing multiple of the
d-pad
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
really
[Music]
oh my God stop it
sorry it says
[Music]
that is one hell of a fight I'm gonna
try whoa guys
I got him get ready to run
look at it I got complete faith I'll be
watching from the car sir
[Music]
I'm not playing around with this dude
foreign
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
also you can come in the chat if you
want us
[Applause]
it's fine
[Music]
[Applause]
man how you get up quicker than you got
a blast makes no sense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this
King Hippo
she's like
[Music]
[Applause]
all right all right wow
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
like nothing's happened
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
nope
he's got a lot of Health there too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
22 seconds I got him down once
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
stuff in the round unfortunately
[Music]
what happens if it goes all all around
do you just automatically lose or
something some of the chat explained
that to me
[Music]
[Applause]
I need information and the chat has it
[Music]
[Music]
get up Little Mac don't do this to me
[Applause]
[Music]
Little Mac failed me
he failed me guys
[Music]
modern technology
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what what
hold up
now hit me again come on
I have to do at the office
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Stars when it's oh I I know that
now that I know how to get a star I'm
gonna get a star and wait for him to do
that
that movie likes to do where he just
teleports over and over again I'm hoping
that might that might get him down
okay
[Music]
oh that sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you ain't done yet little man
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
people be acting like you do that one
time it's a wrap
you lying you're lying
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
numbers it's not letters
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not going down he's been down twice
[Music]
the third time he's went down thank you
[Music]
thank you
ball board
[Music]
he's huge
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a wrap
[Applause]
I got people to to entertain
I can't be going to the same six people
the same 30 years ago
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh I was about to hit him
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
suffering's entertaining for people
seeing the new experiences for me it's
definitely way more entertaining for a
lot of people
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
well I think I don't really care what
accounts of the book of the Lord I'm
trying to do an entertaining stream
[Music]
[Applause]
man he's back up man back up we're gonna
get him right now though we're gonna get
him right now
oh we're not getting with that
[Music]
okay that's cool
that's full you guys saw that you guys
so there's no way you didn't see that
there's no way you didn't see that I hit
him
[Music]
there's no way you guys
[Music]
watching this stop it stop it
it's red I want to recap re-vote
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
trying to get a good hit on him
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a little bit better with that mechanic
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
get up get up I know you ain't ready I
know you ain't done I know you still got
energy in you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh he's about to knock me out man he was
right there he's about to knock me out
there wasn't no more knocking out I
could have done more than him about to
do Me Knocking me out right there
[Applause]
[Music]
I got him now though
oh maybe not
[Music]
I got him I got him
get it and get him man I'm gonna get him
maybe not this time but I got him
get up back please get off get up back
get up
[Music]
watch this watch this chat I got him
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I see that I got that I got him and I
got it
so I know it don't look like it but I
got it
[Music]
I know I don't see much I don't know I
got him and I got him I know I got him
get up man stop it
[Music]
see
I got him I got him I got him okay it's
in my mind he's already beat in my mind
I just I got him
[Music]
watch this Jack
don't watch this don't watch this close
your eyes chat close them close them
open them back up chat you got this I
got it
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
open the backup chat open them
that's the second one
[Music]
quick it up Matt what are you doing
okay
that was the intent man that wasn't the
attempt that wasn't the attempt
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Carolina gamer 22. you believe in
me not like Sinister complaining because
I'm using saves in 2023 trying to
entertain a stream I ain't trying to
play this on myself I'm trying to
entertain and you guys want to see newer
people me fighting you don't want to see
me fighting the same people
see
that look what I get for
talking
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I got it this time man I I I do
because I I'm starting to get his his
move down like his move
I can see how people beat the game it's
just repetitiveness once you keep
playing over and over again you have to
pretty much Master the moves and you
have to do it all in one thing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if I don't I don't it doesn't really
bother me
laughs
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's try just trying to have fun man
that's all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go Chad here we go 21 seconds
already been down one
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
I got like
38 seconds
how much health does he get let's go
[Music]
that should be it that was three that
was three
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all right
wow
[Music]
he is
destroying me
[Music]
oh so you can't Dodge him at all
[Music]
you kept doing it over and over again
[Music]
all right so
thank you
[Music]
I don't want to stand up to him if I I
want the Dodge it
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he's good with that rematch
[Music]
ah you guys say punch him in the stomach
it's just not working out well it's not
working out well for me at all
is he in too much of a hit on me
look this dude weighs 298 pounds I
probably don't even weigh 200. it's
crazy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are straight up trolling me be honest
with me man you got in trouble it's okay
all right I don't blame you chat you
control me
but you're trolling me man you're
trolling me
[Music]
trolley trolley trolliers
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you trolley troll yours man
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
and he just
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's no way
I feel like my aim and my timing
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
foreign
home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
made
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I swear but you guys are trolling me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are you gonna gain your breath man
[Music]
he's just gonna keep doing it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow wow
he hasn't even hit me any
[Music]
I don't understand where you guys keep
saying gut punches though man
[Music]
on the rails then like stop it with the
chat man seriously
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
man you just keep doing it over and over
again I think it might be easier for me
to
just dodge that when he's doing that so
[Music]
I mean to block it
[Music]
[Music]
all right foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's right
all right so you guys want the chat
wasn't trying to troll me the chat will
troll me I get it okay I get it I get it
but unfortunately here in a little bit I
got I do gotta go
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
hahahaha
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
put that in the chat
[Music]
no I was actually in New York not too
long ago to be honest with you
it wasn't
it was probably like
it was in November
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah I've seen that his eyebrowser
are giving away something
[Music]
all right guys I'll give this a couple
more things and then I got to get some
stuff done
[Music]
oh he's definitely flexible he's
definitely flexing on
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I love how they let him sit down for so
long
[Music]
you know
[Music]
Saved by the Bell man I was totally
Saved by the Bell
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's mad noise
[Music]
why do I have half my health
[Music]
[Music]
man how long is he gonna have energy
[Music]
all right you guys I'm done
[Music]
sorry about another 20 minutes
[Music]
see these uh these intermissions
foreign
[Music]
it's got to be on the top there we go
oh my question is should I go and watch
other people do that
see how easy it is but I'm an idiot is
that what you guys want me to do
I can we can react to someone playing
that like without getting hit or
something you guys want that
playing the game
you know I could see how someone could
beat that game without getting hit
yeah sure I mean we'll do it that's fine
uh I'm trying to figure out how to
well let me
let me put myself right here
all right let's look at this
is there a specific video you guys want
me to react to a specific one
the Blindfolded one see but we already
know he he just does it blindfolded I
feel like
we could find something better
he must go off audio cues on audio cues
only
summoning all
or someone suggested one
all right
he did it and
and in 24 minutes is that the one you
guys talking about hold up
is this the one you guys are talking
about
he did it and
it looks like 24 minutes is that the one
14 minutes
oh this one
there's a few of them
I feel like it's this one that you're
talking about
or is that just beating Mike Tyson
which one Chad
nine months ago
uh it's this 24 minutes one
it's got to be this one
desktop audio
Wireless heads uh
all right let's see I see these good
people you guys talking about
you know we don't really have to have
audio
all right let's see we'll turn the audio
slightly
Zachary knocked this dude out
so sad we still have to wait like seven
months now for the World Cup
getting hype for it is there no quick
way of beating this dude
nothing's even relevant for right now
until June and then after that nothing
for another five months
[Music]
oh so you have to is there a specific
why you have to hit him
it's everything
all right let's go to where I was
hold up
all right so that's what I knocked him
out
all right so here's let's see how he
does the hippo
here we go
looking good
foreign
[Music]
how does he know when he's opening his
mouth or is he just
guess he had a 41 flat but
whatever
it's too fast it's gonna be probably
that I don't even think it's a 99
all right so I beat this dude
oh let's see how he beats him so fast
I try to do that I always felt like it
wasn't
there
did he knock him out
[Music]
no
what happened
dude they ain't doing that much damage
like these supers ain't doing that kind
of damage when I use them
foreign
oh so he's getting the star and he's
immediately using it
[Music]
here we go five damn it dude
all right so that's as far as I got
hello
man just abusing that star system
[Music]
who is this dude
[ __ ]
[ __ ] man I lost time
you knocked him out quick uh dude that
Blind Side of Me
foreign
I feel like
I feel like these star moves are doing a
lot more damage than they did with me Mr
man I haven't done select strats in
years
[Music]
have you been weren't you like just
watching my runs like half an hour ago
confused
so you fight him again
really a star a star at all
and even like the fight we got last run
here would be really good
a perfect fight on Tyson but yeah so
this is Mike Tyson
all right
[Music]
foreign
no 217 excuse me this is 117.
all right here we go
[Music]
why
dude well who is this
the pecs he's doing the pexy I can't do
this but he's doing the pass
and we need a community to fight here
be clean
oh he he dismantled that dude
this would be
[Music]
this would be a tiny ass record but
here we go
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah
oh my God
oh my God
this dude
quick Dodge
holy [ __ ]
so a question why'd they take Mike Tyson
out again
can someone explain that to me why they
took Mike Tyson out
what happened
someone get upset or something
well that's what people keep telling me
oh domestic violence oh when he got in
that trouble
I feel that
oh
oh yeah legal issues
that's kind of messed up to take his
stuff away just because he wasn't the
champ it had to have been the legal
issues
oh okay that makes sense it's mainly
about money guys it's always about money
all right I appreciate everyone for
coming through you know it was a an
eventful stream
it was an eventful stream but I'm a
head get uh get some stuff done uh my
back's kind of hurting today I don't
know why I don't feel the greatest today
but uh I appreciate it for coming
through
uh showed up you know I will be on IOP
this week and uh yeah I appreciate
everyone dropping the super chats you
know really supporting the Stream
you know I might I might stream super
punch out one day I don't know I
actually uh I enjoyed this so I'll talk
a little bit more in depth about the
my Impressions on the game on IOP this
Sunday
uh but you know I I did enjoy it I can't
say I did but I'm pretty sure we're
coming through this exotic